today we're going to take a look at how
to get a 2022 Honda Odyssey unlocked
opened and started if the key fob dies
so I've taken the battery out of this
key fob to demonstrate
as you can see none of the buttons are
working so the first thing we need to do
is remove the emergency key that's in
the bottom of the key fob
that's done by pressing this release
here that my thumb's on and then the
emergency key will come out like that
now we use that emergency key to unlock
the driver's door
we'll turn it to the right or clockwise
and then we'll get in in order to get
our Odyssey started with the dead key
fob what we need to do is get in and
press the stop start button
then you hear it beeping and see that
blinking so we'll take our fob and touch
it to the stop start button
you see this glow solid and now we can
start it as normal press the break in
and then you'll just need to change the
battery in your fob as soon as you can